still Adelphia having its way on the
offensive end to start this game they
are 5 of 7 from the floor here's a look
at Carson Edwards hitting from deep
played six games with the Celtics last
year as a matter of fact Edwards deep
rage and showing it off
I mean those two franchises is a good
parking spot depends who's the home team
right I like the DNA of the corporate
gonna be on a roster but it's a great
opportunity as late stage and there's
Carson ain't much good job coming off
that rescreen he's so low to the ground
and he what do you have to work out for
someone are to be in the gym no one that
you're getting ready to play your first
game in stage two and a quarter inches
the highest on record ever at the NBA
Draft Combine he shot 74 percent from
the field for his career that's for
collegiate years that is also an NC
double-a run and robber wins it's up
there to grab that 1 3 back marcin
Edwards no hesitation they awaken it way
to see christyn Williams person Edwards
rather a prolific college scorer already
seen six plays bio giddy hey now 3 100
million dollars for the V Foundation so
thank you for your support
he didn't think when that news broke on
Thursday not a lot of guys in this
league who have and I'm not trying to
defend what he did the other night
because I was with you and Ryan the
whole way but there are a lot of guys
this league who have been agitators and
have made a living off of a plaintiff or
a couple of occasions but he played on
20 now that's chasing a basketball dream
if jr. played 22 teams maze day with New
Orleans since 2010 Edwards gets the best
he's got 14 as quickly as it was a
six-point game delete his tan again
Edwards cleared some space and that's
all he needs pan last year but Carson
Edwards turned into an easy basket for
Bruno Coppola Edwards boo defenders in
front patty still cashes it in what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with bleach
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content